ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément moins de paris
mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus se taire ils
ont des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité la
france oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne
voit jamais
aujourd'hui nous sommes en haute savoie
dans le pays du mont blanc
[Musique]
marie à suppose c'est ça a enchanté donc
là on est à chamonix c'est ça et tu es
saisonnière je devais démarrer
je rêvais démarrer et 18 retrouve sur la
la banque va nous montrer un petit peu
le les établissements ça marche je vais
bosser quoi on voit là eh ben on va
aller se diriger vers place de l'horloge
c'est parti que je pense que toute la
france connait étaient originaires du
cool ou moi non je suis originaire
dessus de chine et à marseille hatem ben
arfa là et je suis venu ici en saison il
ya quatre ans j'ai jamais quitté le de
la montagne
surtout au niveau du boulot ça bouge
énormément plus et c'est ce qui me plaît
quoi ça c'est chamonix place de
l'horloge vide tout vide il n'y a plus
que les locaux il ya deux-trois vin
chaud à droite à gauche mais voilà trois
brasseries fermé qu'est ce que tu fais
tu de patienter et là je commence à
sérieusement inquiéter
je sais pas s'il faut reconvertir s'il
faut attendre si si je dois partir aller
là où il ya du boulot
voilà tu sais pas à quoi je sers ont ils
ont les plus il pas peut-être que tu te
projettes déjà un petit peu sur l'été je
me projette sur l'été alors j'espère que
tous reverra les décors pour travailler
quand même ici à travailler ici voile
ample des potes saisonniers ça va ouais
donc vous aussi dans la galère dans la
galère de la saison ce pour les
saisonniers la merde on n'a plus faim du
chômage et tout se complique et du coup
on a un contre un 3e plan là on essaie
de déménager un peu ailleurs à quoi au
soleil
ouais on voulait aller aux rappels ont
trouvé du boulot et tout on agriculture
tu passes et ray comme beaucoup moi j'ai
moi aussi je me tâte ans je sais pas
normalement c'est chouette
ici à metz et ça c'est du boulot à gogo
quoi on est venu ici parce que vraiment
il ya toujours du boulot quoi
servent-ils c'est un plan vert ce qui se
passe pas bien merci
bats aussi bon courage pour la suite
alors en voilà des amis saisonniers que
la tenir le coup faut rester on est les
petites mains de chamonix quand même
c'est un peu grâce aux saisonniers que
ça fonctionne ça fait mal au coeur un
peu de savoir que tout le monde peut en
fait tu as eu des autres quand même moi
j'ai eu des z alors c'est compliqué
parce que j'aime
mon chômage qui va se terminer et là ça
serait enclenchée sur 1
bougez était pas très bien payé donc ça
va encore aller crescendo vers le bas
born
elle a dit embaucher et vous mettrez les
gens sur mass partiel sauf que il entend
d'ailleurs ils savent pas non plus ou
moins mon nom mon prochain patron il est
dans l'embarras comme pas possible
il aurait voulu me protéger mais ne
sachant pas où aller ils nous voilà j'ai
pas signer un contrat chez pas en
chômage partiel pour toi les mesures
gouvernementales qui ont été prises de
la fermeture des pas des stations mais
des hôtels des restaurants de tous les
lieux accueillant du public mais aussi
des remontées mécaniques pour moi ça
faisait depuis le premier confinement
qu'ils avaient tout mis en place niveau
hygiène distance tous les protocoles
sanitaires
c'était vraiment les premiers à avoir
tout mis en place mais comme il faut et
résultats des comptes
ça fait presque un an pendant que nous
on ne veut pas qu'on bosse pas parce que
franchement les restos ils ont tous mis
en place ouais non mais sa célébrité et
toi donc tu vis aux houches et tu te
déplaces comment moi je me déplace en
scooter
c'est surtout que
ben moi j'aime pas trop de sous ios que
j'avais c'était plus qu'un scooter
voilà que je peut revendre est le jeu
comment moi je veux la jeu alors j'ai
des mois c'est une connaissance qui ma
loge et parce que en agence et où je
pense que j'aurai paris sia a trouvé
quelque chose dans une petite maison un
chalet un petit chalet de 22 mètres
carrés et voilà petit confort et et
j'essaye de patienter et surtout
j'essaie de le garder on va y aller on
lui a dit qu'on ne peut y aller allons-y
allez tu vas vraiment prêt ça change
parce que là il commence à neiger à
faire très prochainement très voilà
voilà il ya jamais eu autant de matches
c'est à dire pas mal
franchement il y en a pas mal quoi ça
tombe mal quoi donc là on arrive si toi
c'est lol ouais petit chalet vous appris
allez merci donc c'est bien sympa assez
coquet petit confort petit chalet cosy
donc là on est aux houches quoi à 10
bornes de chamonix à peu près et du coup
tu là j'avais fait en scoot encore king
si quand même six mois je n'ai acheté la
rôdé mais sinon mais en vrai en bus
sauf que mon travail c'est responsable
du petit déjeuner souvent c'est très tôt
le matin et a pas de bus n'a pas de but
bon du coup tu va nous montrer ce
scooter il est devant l'ag j'ai vu
là-bas tout à l'heure
votre c'est marie pompe autant fini les
missions en fait toujours une photo
traditionnelle pièce
donc tu vois que ça va donner l'idée
quand j'ai vu tant scoop et voilà up
super
[Musique]